House Republicans are considering
whether to force a vote on a resolution
to impeach Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosenstein 11 house conservatives
introduced articles of impeachment
yesterday they accused Rosen Stein who
oversees the special council's Russia
investigation of not being responsive
enough to their requests for documents
no word if that's grounds for
impeachment Paula Reid is at the White
House Paula good morning good morning
this is just the latest in this ongoing
feud between the president's Republican
allies and the Justice Department
now Tea Party leaders mark meadows of
North Carolina and Jim Jordan of Ohio
along with nine others are steering this
effort to try to oust Rosenstein they're
alleging that he has conflicts of
interest in the ongoing Special Counsel
investigation they also accuse him of
intentionally withholding documents in
other ongoing investigations into the
Justice Department and how it handled
investigations related to the 2016
elections now if Rosenstein was
impeached the Russian investigation
would continue but Special Counsel
Muller he would be supervised by a
different senior Justice Department
official Rosenstein has pushed back
against these partisan attacks warning
back in May that the Justice Department
is quote not going to be extorted but
it's unclear how far they're actually
going to be able to get with this effort
or if it could even come to a vote
because several top Republican lawmakers
have said they do not support the idea
of trying to impeach Rosen Stein
including House Oversight Chair trey
Gowdy now the Justice Department has not
commented yet on these efforts Gail all
right thank you very much Paula